bentornato a Capire l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico, mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il
direttore tecnico per l'educazione presso IBM Quantum. Questa è l'undicesima lezione della serie ed è la terza lezione della
terza unità, che riguarda la formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica. Questa lezione tratta le misure, che rappresentano un'
interfaccia tra informazione quantistica e classica. Quando si effettua una misura su un sistema mentre si trova in uno
stato quantistico, viene estratta informazione classica che rivela qualcosa su quello stato quantistico, generalmente modificando o
distruggendo quello stato nel processo. In una formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica, discussa
nella prima unità della serie, di solito limitiamo la nostra attenzione alle misure proiettive, incluso il
tipo più semplice di misura: le misure nella base standard. È tuttavia possibile generalizzare la nozione di misura
e questo si rivela essere una cosa piuttosto utile da fare. In questa lezione parleremo delle misure nella loro generalità
completa, incluso come vengono descritte in termini matematici e come si inseriscono nella formulazione generale dell'informazione
quantistica. Verso la fine della lezione daremo anche uno sguardo a un paio di nozioni fondamentali connesse alle misure, ovvero la discriminazione degli stati quantistici
e la tomografia degli stati quantistici. Quindi cominciamo. Ecco una panoramica della
lezione. Come facciamo spesso, partiremo dalle basi, includendo un paio di modi diversi ma equivalenti con cui
possiamo descrivere le misure in termini matematici. In particolare, possiamo descrivere le misure tramite collezioni di matrici
e possiamo anche descriverle come canali, come ho accennato nella lezione precedente. Discuteremo anche le misure
parziali, ovvero misure eseguite solo su una parte di un sistema composto
più grande. Poi passeremo al teorema di Naimark, che è un fatto fondamentale riguardante le misure e che dice in sostanza
che le misure generali possono sempre essere implementate in modo semplice, reminiscente delle rappresentazioni di Stinespring
dei canali. In breve, le misure generali possono sempre essere implementate introducendo prima un
sistema workspace inizializzato, poi eseguendo un'operazione unitaria e infine eseguendo una misura nella base standard
sul sistema workspace. Questo risulta essere abbastanza facile da dimostrare e vedremo come funziona, e
vedremo anche come questo si collega alle cosiddette misure non distruttive, che descriverò. Infine, nell'ultima parte della
lezione, discuteremo la discriminazione degli stati quantistici e la tomografia degli stati quantistici. Inizieremo con le descrizioni
matematiche delle misure. Le misure ci forniscono un'interfaccia tra informazione quantistica e
classica. Quando si effettua una misura su un sistema mentre si trova in uno stato quantistico, viene estratta informazione classica
su quello stato quantistico. Inoltre lo stato quantistico viene generalmente modificato o possibilmente
completamente distrutto. Inizialmente concentreremo la nostra attenzione sulle cosiddette misure distruttive, in cui
uno stato quantistico entra e ne esce solo informazione classica, quindi non c'è specifica del
postmeasurement quantum state del sistema misurato. Parlando in modo intuitivo, possiamo immaginare che una misura distruttiva
distrugga qualsiasi sistema venga misurato, quindi il suo stato dopo la misura non è
specificato. Questo non significa letteralmente che i dispositivi fisici vengano necessariamente distrutti: è solo una descrizione
matematica ed è molto utile perché aiuta a mantenere le cose semplici e a concentrarsi sugli aspetti
matematici essenziali delle misure. Ci sono in particolare due modi equivalenti per descrivere le misure
distruttive, di cui ho parlato durante la panoramica della lezione. Un modo per descrivere una misura
distruttiva è tramite una collezione di matrici, in cui abbiamo in particolare una matrice per ogni possibile esito della misura.
Un secondo modo per descrivere una misura distruttiva è tramite un canale, in cui
l'input è lo stato di qualsiasi sistema venga misurato e l'output è sempre una matrice densità diagonale, che possiamo
interpretare come una descrizione di una distribuzione di probabilità sugli esiti classici possibili della misura.
Le due descrizioni sono equivalenti, e questo è abbastanza utile perché ci permette di scegliere la descrizione più conveniente in una
data situazione. Parleremo anche delle misure non distruttive, in cui oltre a un esito di misura classico
viene specificato anche il postmeasurement quantum state del sistema misurato.
Le misure non distruttive sono importanti e si presentano frequentemente, ma c'è un senso in cui non sono
fondamentali quanto le misure distruttive. In termini matematici, in particolare, come si scopre,
le misure non distruttive possono sempre essere descritte come composizioni di canali e misure distruttive, e
vedremo come funziona un po' più avanti nella lezione. Ora vediamo come le misure, intese come misure distruttive,
possono essere descritte come collezioni di matrici. In tutta questa discussione supporremo che X sia un sistema che viene
misurato e, per semplicità, faremo un paio di assunzioni. Prima di tutto assumeremo che il
Classical State set di X sia costituito dagli interi da 0 a n meno uno per qualche intero positivo n, e i possibili
esiti della misura sono gli interi da 0 a M meno uno, di nuovo per qualche intero positivo M. Non c'è
alcuna relazione necessaria tra i numeri n e M: sono entrambi interi positivi arbitrari. E ovviamente potremmo sostituire
questi insiemi con Classical State set arbitrari se volessimo farlo. Prima ricordiamo come funzionano le misure
proiettive, di cui abbiamo parlato per la prima volta nella terza lezione della serie. Dato che stiamo assumendo che
gli esiti della misura siano gli interi da 0 a n meno uno, descriviamo una misura proiettiva tramite una collezione
di proiezioni Pi 0 fino a Pi M meno uno, che sommano alla matrice identità, e queste matrici hanno tutte righe e
colonne corrispondenti agli stati classici di X, ovvero sono tutte matrici n per n.
Se x si trova in uno stato quantistico descritto da un vettore di stato quantistico s, allora ogni possibile esito della misura
a appare con probabilità pari alla norma euclidea al quadrato di Pi a moltiplicata
per il vettore s. La norma euclidea al quadrato di qualsiasi vettore è uguale al prodotto interno di quel
vettore con se stesso, quindi otteniamo l'espressione mostrata sullo schermo, e possiamo semplificarla un
po' usando il fatto che Pi a è una proiezione, quindi moltiplicarla per se stessa non fa
nulla. E infine possiamo riscrivere l'espressione ottenuta in modo leggermente diverso usando la proprietà ciclica
WEBVTT
della traccia, come mostrato sullo schermo. E se non è chiaro perché vogliamo scrivere l'espressione in questo modo,
la risposta breve è che vogliamo capire come funzionano le misure proiettive per le
matrici densità. In particolare per linearità abbiamo che se lo stato di X è descritto da una matrice densità rho piuttosto
che da un vettore di stato quantistico s, allora la probabilità che l'esito a appaia è data dalla traccia della proiezione
Pi a per la matrice densità rho. Deve essere così perché, come abbiamo visto,
possiamo sempre pensare a una matrice densità come a una media pesata di stati puri e, se facciamo la media delle
probabilità corrispondenti, otteniamo questa espressione perché la traccia è una funzione lineare. Quindi questa è l'espressione che stiamo
cercando, e possiamo riordinare le cose un po' per concentrarci sulle
matrici densità. Il punto principale di questo, tra l'altro, è stabilire un punto di riferimento rispetto a ciò che abbiamo già imparato
e vedere che questa descrizione delle misure proiettive è in realtà un caso speciale di una descrizione più generale delle misure che
stiamo per vedere. Quindi quello che farò ora è sostituire questa descrizione di come funzionano le misure proiettive per le matrici densità
con la descrizione per le misure generali, in modo da capire la relazione. Ed eccola
qui. Una misura generale, non necessariamente proiettiva, è descritta da una collezione di matrici semidefinite positive
P 0 fino a PM meno uno che sommano all'identità. E se questa misura viene eseguita su X mentre si trova
in uno stato descritto da una matrice densità rho, allora ogni esito a appare con probabilità uguale alla traccia di PA per
rho. In breve, l'unica cosa che è cambiata è che abbiamo rilassato la condizione su queste matrici. In particolare le matrici
non devono essere matrici di proiezione: devono solo essere semidefinite positive. Di conseguenza ho sostituito la lettera Pi con la lettera P,
perché Pi è un nome convenzionale per una proiezione, mentre preferisco usare la lettera P per le matrici semidefinite
positive. Questa è una generalizzazione della descrizione che avevamo per le misure proiettive, tra l'altro, perché le matrici di proiezione sono sempre semidefinite
positive e in realtà possono essere alternativamente definite come matrici semidefinite positive i cui autovalori
possono essere solo zero e uno. Possiamo osservare che questa definizione
ha senso nel senso che otteniamo sempre un vettore di probabilità per le probabilità degli esiti, nel modo
seguente. Prima di tutto, questi numeri che ho chiamato probabilità degli esiti sono sempre numeri reali non negativi: questo
perché sia PA che rho sono semidefinite positive e la traccia del prodotto di due matrici semidefinite positive
è sempre un numero reale non negativo, e lascio a te capire perché
sia così. In secondo luogo, i numeri devono sommare a uno perché la traccia è lineare,
le matrici P 0 fino a PN meno uno devono sommare all'identità e le matrici densità hanno traccia uguale a
uno, quindi indipendentemente da quale matrice densità rho abbiamo scelto, le probabilità degli esiti formeranno sempre un
vettore di probabilità. Ora vediamo alcuni esempi. Ho già detto che
le misure proiettive sono un caso speciale delle misure generali perché le proiezioni sono sempre semidefinite positive.
Ma è bello partire semplice, quindi iniziamo con una misura nella base standard di un qubit. Possiamo rappresentare una misura nella base standard
di un qubit con due matrici P 0 e P1 definite come mostrato sullo schermo. P 0 è ket zero bra zero e P1 è ket uno
bra uno. Queste sono entrambe matrici semidefinite positive e sono in effetti proiezioni, e sommano chiaramente all'
identità, quindi insieme descrivono una misura. Se applichiamo questa misura a un qubit
in uno stato descritto da una matrice densità rho, allora la probabilità che l'esito zero appaia è la traccia di P 0 per rho,
e la probabilità che l'esito uno appaia è la traccia di P1 per rho. Usando la proprietà ciclica della traccia otteniamo
le due voci diagonali di rho, come ci aspettiamo. Ecco un altro esempio, in cui
questa volta le matrici non sono proiezioni. Sono però semidefinite positive e capita che siano anche matrici densità,
ma questo non è importante. Ciò che conta è che sommino all'identità, quindi insieme descrivono una
misura. Possiamo vedere cosa succede quando questa misura viene eseguita su un qubit nello stato più, per esempio, solo per
vedere come funziona per un esempio di stato. Il calcolo delle probabilità è mostrato sullo
schermo. Nota in particolare che sebbene lo stato più sia uno stato puro e possiamo rappresentare quello stato dal vettore di stato quantistico ket Plus, dobbiamo
inserire la rappresentazione come matrice densità di quello stato, che è ket plus bra plus, nelle formule per ottenere
le probabilità. E lasciami anche osservare che poiché stiamo parlando di una misura distruttiva, non c'è alcuna
specifica del postmeasurement quantum state di questo qubit, quindi tutto ciò che abbiamo è una specifica delle
probabilità degli esiti. Ecco un ultimo esempio per ora, ed è abbastanza interessante. Ancora una volta è una misura di un
singolo qubit e per descriverla inizieremo definendo quattro vettori di stato quantistico noti come stati
tetraedrici. La ragione per cui si chiamano stati tetraedrici è che corrispondono ai quattro vertici di
un tetraedro regolare inscritto nella sfera di Bloch. Per essere precisi, quando diciamo che questo è un tetraedro regolare
intendiamo un solido a quattro facce in cui ciascuna delle facce è un triangolo equilatero. C'è quindi una perfetta simmetria: ogni
spigolo ha la stessa lunghezza e lo stesso angolo è formato tra due spigoli adiacenti qualsiasi.
Ora possiamo definire una misura interessante con quattro possibili esiti, come mostrato sullo schermo. In parole, possiamo prendere le nostre
matrici come le rappresentazioni come matrice densità di questi stati divise per due. Queste sono sicuramente
matrici semidefinite positive perché sono matrici densità divise per due, e potresti fare i calcoli per verificare
che sommano effettivamente all'identità. Ma un altro modo per vederlo è pensare alla simmetria: se facciamo la media di questi quattro stati
otteniamo lo stato completamente misto, che si trova al centro della sfera di Bloch. Ma poiché stiamo dividendo
ciascuno per due anziché per quattro, otteniamo il doppio dello stato completamente misto, che è l'identità. Non dirò altro su
questa misura per ora, tranne osservare che non è una misura proiettiva, ma è un bel esempio e
la vedremo ripresentarsi più avanti nella lezione. Un altro modo per descrivere le misure generali è come canali, come ora
discuteremo. L'idea qui è che gli stati probabilistici classici possono essere rappresentati da matrici densità diagonali, e quindi
poiché gli esiti delle misure sono classici, possiamo pensare alle misure come canali il cui output è sempre una matrice densità diagonale
WEBVTT
che descrive l'esito della misura. Quindi vediamo questo in modo un po' più dettagliato. Se pensiamo in modo
astratto a una misura generale, possiamo descrivere quella misura come un canale fi. Il sistema di input per il canale è
qualunque sistema X viene misurato e il sistema di output è un sistema Y i cui stati classici corrispondono agli
esiti della misura, che stiamo prendendo come gli interi da 0 a n meno uno per qualche intero positivo
M. E poiché gli esiti delle misure sono classici, richiediamo che per ogni matrice densità di input rho per il sistema
X, l'output fi(rho) sia una matrice densità diagonale. Per esempio, se pensiamo a una
misura nella base standard di un qubit e pensiamo a quella misura come descritta da un canale, possiamo esprimerla come abbiamo qui sullo schermo.
Se la matrice densità di input è rho, otterremo l'esito zero con probabilità uguale a bra 0 rho ket zero
e otterremo l'esito uno con probabilità bra uno rho ket uno. Quindi se esprimiamo questi
esiti classici della misura come matrici densità, otterremo questa espressione per il canale corrispondente. E si scopre
che non è altro che il canale di de-phasing completo. Ed è coerente con l'idea che il canale di de-phasing completo
rappresenti una forma estrema di decoerenza, che può significare cose diverse, ma quando uso quel termine mi
riferisco alla tendenza degli stati quantistici a diventare classici perché l'ambiente intorno a qualunque sistema
stiamo considerando sta osservando in qualche senso, o in altre parole sta misurando.
Quindi gli esiti delle misure possono essere descritti come canali, come ho appena descritto. Ma questa non è solo una possibilità: è una
caratterizzazione delle misure generali. E quello che intendo con questo è il seguente. Ovviamente ci sono canali
che non rappresentano misure perché l'output potrebbe non essere sempre una matrice densità diagonale. Ma se è
il caso che l'output di un canale sia sempre una matrice densità diagonale indipendentemente dallo stato di input rho che scegliamo, allora è necessariamente possibile
esprimere quel canale nella forma mostrata sullo schermo per qualche scelta di una misura, intesa come collezione di
matrici semidefinite positive che sommano all'identità. Ed è bello per molteplici ragioni, tra cui il fatto che
ci dice in sostanza che la nostra definizione di misure come collezioni di matrici non manca di
nulla. Un altro modo per dire questo è che questo modo di pensare alle misure come canali è operativo
o forse assiomatico, nel senso che cattura ciò che una misura dovrebbe essere: un processo fisico che
trasforma l'informazione quantistica in informazione classica. E si scopre che è completamente equivalente alla nostra prima
descrizione delle misure, che è puramente algebrica. Non mostrerò la dimostrazione dell'equivalenza in questo video, ma
non è difficile e se sei interessato puoi trovare la dimostrazione nel materiale scritto per la lezione, che è linkato nella descrizione
del video. Abbiamo discusso cosa succede quando una misura generale viene eseguita su un sistema in un dato stato,
almeno nel caso delle misure distruttive. Poi parleremo delle misure parziali, ovvero che
viene misurata solo una parte di un sistema composto. Per essere precisi, supponiamo di avere una coppia di sistemi XZ che
insieme si trovano in uno stato descritto da una matrice densità rho, e una misura descritta da una collezione di matrici semidefinite positive che sommano all'
identità viene eseguita sul solo sistema X. Naturalmente questo risulta in un
esito della misura. E poiché stiamo parlando di misure distruttive, possiamo immaginare che il processo di misura distrugga il sistema
X, ma abbiamo ancora il sistema Z di cui preoccuparci e dobbiamo capire come la misura di X influisce sullo
stato di Z. Prima parliamo delle probabilità degli
esiti. Poiché stiamo parlando di una misura del solo sistema X, le probabilità per i diversi
esiti possono dipendere solo dallo stato di X in isolamento, ovvero possono dipendere solo dallo
stato ridotto di X. In particolare, la probabilità che un dato esito a appaia è data dalla
stessa formula di prima, che è la traccia di PA per lo stato ridotto di X, che denotiamo con rho
subX. Lo stato rho subX si ottiene da rho tracciando su Z, quindi possiamo fare quella
sostituzione. E sebbene potrebbe non essere immediatamente ovvio, la formula che otteniamo può essere scritta alternativamente come
mostrato sullo schermo: è la traccia di PA tensorizzato con la matrice identità sul sistema Z per
rho. Questa è un'uguaglianza che vale sicuramente la pena di verificare con un po' di tempo. È intuitiva: non stiamo facendo
nulla a Z, quindi ha senso che l'identità su Z appaia in questo modo. Ma può anche essere verificata
algebricamente, e lascio questo a te, insieme al suggerimento di considerare prima il caso in cui rho è un prodotto tensoriale di due matrici e poi
usare la linearità per concludere che deve funzionare per ogni rho. E dirò anche che non dipende dal fatto che PA
sia semidefinita positiva o che rho sia una matrice densità. Questa è un'uguaglianza che funzionerebbe per qualsiasi scelta di
matrici al posto di PA e rho, purché abbiano le dimensioni giuste perché l'espressione abbia
senso. Ora vediamo come lo stato di Z viene influenzato dalla misura. L'approccio naturale,
a mio avviso, è pensare alla misura come a un canale. Ecco il canale che associamo alla nostra misura, e stiamo
pensando a questo come a un canale dal sistema X a un nuovo sistema Y i cui stati classici corrispondono agli esiti della misura. Quindi in questa formula
Sigma rappresenta uno stato del solo sistema X. Se applichiamo questo canale al
sistema X mentre la coppia XZ si trova nello stato rho, otterremo la matrice densità che abbiamo proprio qui. Di nuovo,
prenditi tutto il tempo necessario per verificarlo, e di nuovo il mio suggerimento è di considerare prima il caso in cui rho è un prodotto
tensoriale di due matrici e poi usare la linearità. Abbiamo visto questo tipo di stato
in cui il primo sistema è classico e il secondo sistema è quantistico come esempio nella lezione sulle matrici
densità. Ogni a appare con una certa probabilità, che è la traccia del secondo fattore tensoriale, quindi puoi pensare
a questi secondi fattori tensoriali come matrici densità moltiplicate per probabilità. Quindi per ottenere lo stato di
Z condizionato all'ottenimento di un particolare esito a, semplicemente dividiamo per la probabilità, ovvero in altre parole
normalizziamo il secondo fattore tensoriale dividendolo per la sua stessa traccia. Quindi in sintesi, se eseguiamo una
misura su X mentre la coppia XZ si trova nello stato rho, questo è ciò che accade. Prima ogni esito a appare
con probabilità uguale alla traccia di PA tensorizzato con l'identità per rho. In secondo luogo, condizionato all'ottenimento di
WEBVTT
un particolare esito a, lo stato di Z è dato dall'espressione mostrata sullo schermo, che è ciò che otteniamo
normalizzando la matrice che abbiamo visto poco fa. Ed è la stessa cosa che dividere la matrice per la probabilità
che a appaia. Devo menzionare che questo ha senso solo se la probabilità è diversa da zero, altrimenti staremmo
dividendo per zero. Ma va bene perché non dobbiamo preoccuparci di cose che non accadono. In questa parte della
lezione discuteremo un teorema semplice ma fondamentale sulle misure, noto come teorema di Naimark.
In breve, ciò che dice è che qualsiasi misura può essere implementata come suggerisce la figura sullo schermo.
Per dirlo a parole, una data misura generale su un sistema X può essere implementata nel seguente modo.
Introduciamo prima un sistema workspace inizializzato Y i cui stati classici sono i possibili esiti della misura, che stiamo assumendo siano
numerati da 0 a n meno uno. Poi viene eseguita un'operazione unitaria U sulla coppia
YX e poi viene eseguita una misura nella base standard su Y. Quindi tutto è sostanzialmente fissato
tranne la scelta di U. Il teorema dice che è in effetti possibile scegliere questa operazione
unitaria U in modo che le probabilità per i diversi esiti concordino sempre con la data misura
generale. Ora vediamo come viene dimostrato il teorema di Naimark, e non è difficile. Dobbiamo solo fare una buona scelta per
l'operazione unitaria U e verificare che funzioni. Ma prima abbiamo bisogno di un fatto di base
dalla teoria delle matrici: per qualsiasi matrice semidefinita positiva P, esiste sempre una unica matrice semidefinita positiva
Q tale che Q al quadrato è uguale a P. In generale potrebbero esserci molte matrici che elevate al quadrato danno P, ma
ce n'è sempre solo una che è semidefinita positiva. La notazione che usiamo per denotare questa matrice è la radice quadrata di
P, ed è anche come la chiamiamo a parole. Se vuoi calcolare la radice quadrata di P per una qualche
matrice semidefinita positiva P, puoi farlo calcolando prima una decomposizione spettrale di P e poi
sostituendo ciascuno degli autovalori con la sua radice quadrata, lasciando gli autovettori invariati. Gli autovalori sono tutti non
negativi, quindi questo ha senso, ed è abbastanza facile vedere che la matrice che otteniamo è in effetti semidefinita positiva
e elevata al quadrato dà P. Il fatto che sia unica è una questione diversa: non è difficile
dimostrarlo usando alcuni fatti di base sulle matrici, ma è un po' tangenziale rispetto alla lezione e prenderemo quella parte
come data per acquisita. E ora che abbiamo quel concetto a portata di mano, è abbastanza facile specificare una
operazione unitaria U che funzioni. Qualsiasi matrice unitaria che corrisponda al modello mostrato sullo schermo funzionerà in effetti.
Le prime n colonne, assumendo che X abbia n stati classici come prima, si ottengono sovrapponendo le radici quadrate delle
matrici che descrivono la misura, e le colonne rimanenti possono essere qualsiasi cosa
vogliamo: non fa alcuna differenza, purché l'intera matrice sia unitaria.
E, tra l'altro, se noti una somiglianza con la connessione tra le rappresentazioni di Kraus e Stinespring dei canali, non è una coincidenza. In
realtà quello che abbiamo qui è essenzialmente un caso speciale di quello, in cui le nostre matrici di Kraus sono tutte semidefinite
positive. Quindi ci sono due cose da verificare. La prima è che questa scelta di U funzioni effettivamente, e la
seconda è che sia possibile scegliere le colonne non specificate in modo da rendere U unitaria. Quindi partiamo dalla prima.
Ecco lo stato da cui partiamo: il sistema in basso Y è inizializzato allo stato zero mentre il sistema in alto
parte nello stato rho. Poi eseguiamo U, il che significa che coniughiamo per
U. Possiamo scrivere tutto questo in termini di matrici a blocchi come mostrato sullo schermo: abbiamo U a sinistra, U dagger a
destra, e ket zero bra zero tensorizzato con rho al centro, che assume la forma che abbiamo qui, dove troviamo rho nell'
angolo in alto a sinistra e zeri ovunque altro. E se pensi a questo prodotto per un momento, è evidente che le
voci non specificate di U non hanno importanza perché vengono sempre moltiplicate per le voci zero di questa
matrice centrale. E se eseguiamo la moltiplicazione, otteniamo questa
matrice mostrata proprio qui, descritta come matrice a blocchi. Oppure possiamo esprimerla usando la notazione diretta
in questo modo. Questa è in effetti la forma più comoda per noi, quindi concentriamoci su questa
espressione. E per comodità diamo a questa matrice, che è una matrice densità, il nome
Sigma. L'ultimo passo è la misura nella base standard su Y, quindi calcoliamo lo stato ridotto in Y e
questo è facile data l'espressione che abbiamo: semplicemente tracciamo su X, che corrisponde al secondo fattore
tensoriale. Quindi la probabilità che un dato esito a appaia è la voce diagonale corrispondente ad a. Possiamo scrivere
questo così, e equivale alla traccia della radice quadrata di PA per rho per la radice quadrata
di PA. Usando la proprietà ciclica della traccia otteniamo la traccia di PA per rho,
che è quello che speravamo. Quindi le probabilità per i diversi esiti sono corrette: concordano sempre
con la misura originale da cui siamo partiti. La seconda cosa da verificare
è che sia possibile riempire le colonne non specificate di U in modo tale da renderla
unitaria. Questo segue dal fatto che le prime n colonne, che sono quelle formate dalle radici quadrate delle matrici che descrivono la
misura, sono ortonormali, e questo può essere verificato abbastanza direttamente. I dettagli rilevanti sono qui
sullo schermo, quindi metti in pausa il video e prenditi qualche momento per rifletterci se vuoi. Ma come ho suggerito prima,
è in realtà un caso speciale di qualcosa che abbiamo incontrato nella lezione precedente, e questa è la
dimostrazione. Finora nella lezione abbiamo mantenuto la nostra attenzione sulle misure distruttive, il che significa che non c'è specifica del
postmeasurement quantum state del sistema misurato. Per una misura non distruttiva, d'altra parte, c'è
non solo un esito classico della misura ma anche un postmeasurement quantum state del sistema misurato. E come
vedremo, c'è una connessione naturale con il teorema di Naimark. Ci sono in effetti diversi modi per formulare le misure
non distruttive in termini matematici, ma inizieremo con una formulazione che viene direttamente dal teorema di
Naimark. Considera una misura generale, ovvero distruttiva, descritta da una collezione di matrici semidefinite positive
P 0 fino a PN meno uno che sommano all'identità. Possiamo quindi trasformare questa
WEBVTT
misura in una misura non distruttiva semplicemente considerando l'implementazione di questa misura discussa nel contesto del teorema di
Naimark. Introduciamo un nuovo sistema Y, lo facciamo interagire con X attraverso un'operazione unitaria U e poi eseguiamo una misura nella base standard
su Y. Quindi il sistema X è ancora presente e possiamo considerare il suo
stato. Basandoci sull'analisi che abbiamo svolto, possiamo determinare che il postmeasurement state di X condizionato
all'ottenimento di un particolare esito a è dato da una matrice densità che assomiglia a
questa. In parole, coniughiamo per la radice quadrata della corrispondente matrice di misura e poi
normalizziamo. Un altro modo per formulare le misure non distruttive, più generale, è in termini di matrici di Kraus
dei canali. Questa è la definizione di misure che si trova nel noto libro di testo di Nielsen e
Chuang, per esempio. Supponiamo che m0 fino a m m meno uno siano matrici quadrate che soddisfano
l'equazione mostrata sullo schermo, ovvero che potremmo pensare a queste matrici come matrici di Kraus che descrivono un
canale. In effetti queste matrici descrivono un canale, ma descrivono anche una misura non distruttiva.
Il modo in cui funziona quando un sistema in un dato stato rho viene misurato è: prima le probabilità degli esiti sono
date dall'equazione mostrata sullo schermo. Ogni esito appare con probabilità uguale alla traccia di Ma per
rho per Ma dagger. E condizionato all'esito a, lo stato del sistema
misurato appare così. Le misure non distruttive di questo tipo possono essere implementate in modo
simile a quanto avevamo per il teorema di Naimark, e lascio questo a te da considerare se
vuoi. È possibile generalizzare il concetto di misura non distruttiva ancora oltre. Per esempio
esiste un concetto di cosiddetto strumento quantistico che a volte è abbastanza utile, ma non lo tratterò in questo
video. Nell'ultima parte della lezione discuterò brevemente due compiti associati alle misure: la discriminazione degli stati quantistici e la tomografia degli stati
quantistici. C'è molto da dire su entrambi questi concetti e ne stiamo solo scalfendo la
superficie. Iniziamo chiarendo a cosa si riferiscono questi termini e come differiscono.
Prima di tutto, la discriminazione degli stati quantistici. L'idea è che abbiamo una collezione nota di stati quantistici
di qualche sistema, insieme a probabilità associate a questi stati. Quindi per essere precisi, supponiamo
che rho 0 fino a rho M meno uno siano matrici densità che rappresentano i possibili stati quantistici di un sistema X, e P 0
fino a PN meno uno siano probabilità associate a questi stati. Quindi se raccogliamo le probabilità in un singolo
vettore, otteniamo un vettore di probabilità. Un modo conciso per dirlo, tra l'altro, è che abbiamo un ensemble di stati quantistici.
E ora un modo astratto con cui possiamo pensare alla discriminazione degli stati quantistici come compito o come problema
è il seguente: prima un numero tra zero e N meno uno viene scelto casualmente secondo le probabilità. Il sistema X viene poi
preparato nello stato corrispondente al numero scelto casualmente. L'obiettivo è determinare tramite
una misura di X quale numero è stato scelto. Quindi abbiamo un numero finito di
alternative insieme a un prior, e l'obiettivo è determinare quale alternativa si è effettivamente verificata. Per alcune scelte di stati e
probabilità questo può essere facile, e per altre potrebbe non essere possibile farlo senza qualche possibilità di commettere un errore.
Ci sono varie domande specifiche che potremmo porre, come ad esempio qual è la probabilità minima di commettere un errore
e come appare una misura che raggiunge questa probabilità minima di errore. La tomografia degli stati quantistici, d'altra
parte, è diversa. Qui abbiamo uno stato quantistico sconosciuto di un sistema, quindi
tipicamente non c'è un prior o alcuna informazione sulle alternative possibili. Questa volta però non è una singola copia dello stato ad essere resa
disponibile, ma piuttosto molte copie indipendenti vengono rese disponibili. Ovvero, per qualche numero possibilmente grande
n, abbiamo n sistemi identici X1 fino a Xn che sono stati ciascuno preparato indipendentemente nello stato
rho. E questa volta l'obiettivo è trovare un'approssimazione di questo stato quantistico sconosciuto come matrice densità, misurando
i sistemi. Quindi in sintesi, nella discriminazione degli stati quantistici abbiamo una singola copia dello
stato e stiamo cercando di discriminare tra un numero finito di alternative note. Nella tomografia degli stati quantistici abbiamo molte copie indipendenti
di uno stato quantistico sconosciuto e l'obiettivo è trovare una descrizione di quello stato o almeno una buona approssimazione di
esso. La discriminazione degli stati quantistici è interessante perché astrae un tipo di situazione che si presenta comunemente in
calcolo e crittografia, per esempio, dove una delle alternative di un insieme finito di possibilità si è verificata e noi o qualcun altro sta cercando
di capire quale sia misurando un sistema quantistico. Il caso non banale più semplice è
quello in cui ci sono solo due alternative, ovvero M è uguale a due, quindi il compito è discriminare tra una coppia
di stati. Questo caso risulta essere essenzialmente un problema completamente risolto, assumendo che l'obiettivo sia minimizzare
la probabilità di una discriminazione errata. C'è una scelta ottimale per una misura e si chiama spesso
misura di Helstrom. È in effetti una misura proiettiva e può essere descritta come
segue. Prima consideriamo la differenza pesata tra le due alternative, ovvero P 0 per rho 0 meno P1 per rho uno,
quindi moltiplichiamo la probabilità di estrarre ciascuno di questi due stati per gli stati stessi e prendiamo la
differenza. Questa è una matrice hermitiana perché è uguale al proprio coniugato trasposto, quindi ha una decomposizione
spettrale e sappiamo in particolare che gli autovalori sono tutti numeri reali. Quindi supponiamo di avere una
decomposizione spettrale scritta nella forma mostrata sullo schermo. Quello che facciamo poi è raccogliere gli
autovalori in due insiemi, in cui tutti gli autovalori positivi sono in un insieme e tutti gli autovalori negativi sono nell'
altro. Per essere precisi, prendiamo S0 come l'insieme di tutti gli indici k per cui il corrispondente autovalore Lambda K è
non negativo, e S1 come gli indici rimanenti, che sono quelli corrispondenti agli autovalori
negativi. Non importa in realtà quale insieme contenga gli indici corrispondenti agli autovalori zero. Qui stiamo facendo
una scelta arbitraria di includerli in S0, ma non farebbe alcuna differenza se alcuni o tutti fossero inclusi in S1. Ciò che conta davvero è
che stiamo separando gli autovalori positivi e negativi. E infine definiamo due proiezioni Pi
0 e Pi 1 come mostrato sullo schermo. In parole, Pi 0 è la proiezione sul
WEBVTT
sottospazio generato dagli autovettori corrispondenti agli autovalori non negativi, e Pi 1 è la proiezione sul sottospazio
generato dagli autovettori corrispondenti agli autovalori negativi. Queste sono in effetti proiezioni e
se le sommiamo otteniamo la matrice identità, perché gli autovettori S 0 fino a S N meno uno formano una
base ortonormale. Se questa misura viene eseguita nella situazione in esame, ovvero che
lo stato misurato è rho 0 con probabilità P 0 e rho uno con probabilità P1, allora si scopre che
la probabilità di una identificazione corretta ha una formula abbastanza semplice in termini degli autovalori Lambda 0 fino a Lambda n meno
uno. Non mostrerò i dettagli del calcolo in questo video. Puoi consultare il contenuto scritto linkato nella descrizione del video se sei
interessato, oppure vedere se riesci a convincerti che questa formula sia effettivamente corretta. Possiamo anche esprimere questa
probabilità usando una norma matriciale, comunemente chiamata norma della traccia. Ha una notazione simile alla norma euclidea per i vettori,
eccetto che abbiamo un pedice di uno per indicare che è la norma della traccia. La norma della traccia è molto importante ed è
molto comunemente incontrata nel Quantum Computing, ma non ne dirò molto di più in questa lezione. Un modo per
definirla per le matrici hermitiane è che è la somma dei valori assoluti degli autovalori, quindi puoi pensare
a questa seconda uguaglianza come conseguente direttamente da quella definizione. La norma della traccia può anche essere
definita in altri modi più generali, e incontreremo la norma della traccia nuovamente nella prossima lezione. Questa è in effetti
la cosa migliore che puoi fare: questa misura è ottimale assumendo che il tuo obiettivo sia massimizzare la probabilità di una
risposta corretta. Questo fatto è talvolta chiamato teorema di Holevo-Helstrom ed è anche talvolta chiamato semplicemente teorema di
Helstrom. Quindi non puoi battere questa misura in termini di probabilità di correttezza. Ed è bello perché
c'è una ricetta semplice per la misura stessa e una formula esatta per la probabilità di correttezza in termini della norma della
traccia. La norma della traccia è spesso usata come modo per misurare la differenza osservabile tra matrici densità proprio
per questa ragione. E quando si parla di distanza della traccia tra stati, ci si riferisce tipicamente a
un mezzo per la norma della traccia della differenza tra le due matrici densità, che qui corrisponde al caso in cui P 0 e P1 sono entrambi 1/2, il che
è un caso naturale da considerare. La discriminazione degli stati quantistici per due stati è risolta in modo ottimale dalla
misura di Helstrom, per cui abbiamo una ricetta semplice e una formula semplice per la probabilità di
correttezza. Quindi cosa succede quando vogliamo discriminare tra tre o più stati? In questo caso non abbiamo una
formula generale per una scelta ottimale di misura, né una semplice espressione per la probabilità massima di
correttezza. È tuttavia possibile trovare una buona approssimazione di una misura ottimale con l'aiuto di un computer,
e in particolare questo può essere fatto usando una tecnica di ottimizzazione davvero affascinante e potente nota come programmazione semidefinita. Ma non è
qualcosa che puoi implementare con una matita e un foglio di carta, per esempio. D'altra parte, se qualcuno
ti dà una descrizione di una misura e sostiene che questa misura è ottimale per un compito di discriminazione degli stati quantistici, allora è
in realtà molto facile verificare o falsificare questa affermazione, e questo potrebbe essere fatto usando le cosiddette condizioni di Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax. Non spiegherò cosa sono in questo video, ma sono condizioni semplici ed è piuttosto affascinante
che questo sia possibile. Ecco un esempio che si ricollega agli stati tetraedrici
che abbiamo visto in precedenza nella lezione. Supponiamo di ricevere uno di questi quattro stati, scelto a caso con
probabilità un quarto per ciascuno, e il nostro obiettivo è determinare quale stato ci è stato dato. Non sorprende forse, ma
la scelta migliore che puoi fare per una misura a tale scopo è la misura tetraedrica. Non puoi sempre fare
qualcosa del genere per una collezione arbitraria di stati puri, ma grazie alle simmetrie coinvolte qui questo
funziona e otteniamo in effetti una misura valida. E attraverso le condizioni di Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax che ho menzionato
poco fa, si scopre che è abbastanza semplice dimostrare che questa è in effetti una scelta ottimale di
misura. In particolare, ciò che succede qui è che la misura è sempre corretta con probabilità 1/2. Il che non è
male perché ci sono quattro alternative, quindi la probabilità di una risposta corretta è il doppio rispetto a quella casuale. E
capita che sia il meglio che puoi fare per questi stati. Ora dirò solo qualcosa in più sulla tomografia degli stati quantistici,
dove abbiamo molte copie indipendenti di uno stato quantistico sconosciuto e l'obiettivo è trovare un'approssimazione della matrice densità che descrive
quello stato. Esistono in realtà diverse varianti di questo problema che dipendono dalle tue assunzioni e in
particolare dal tipo di misure che permetti. Per esempio, potremmo richiedere che ogni sistema venga misurato individualmente e
i risultati vengano combinati in qualche modo per arrivare a una descrizione della matrice densità. Oppure potremmo permettere a tutti i
sistemi di essere misurati insieme come un unico sistema composto, il che è molto meglio in teoria ma anche molto più
impegnativo dal punto di vista tecnologico. Oltre alle scelte che si fanno per le misure, c'è
anche un'importante considerazione: come ricostruire una descrizione della matrice densità dai dati che
si ottengono dalle misure. Non entrerò nei dettagli su questo. Il mio punto è semplicemente di suggerire
che la tomografia degli stati quantistici è davvero più un concetto generale con molte varianti diverse, piuttosto che una
singola procedura. C'è stata una grande quantità di ricerche su questo problema, inclusi alcuni risultati
piuttosto recenti che collegano il numero di copie n alla precisione dell'approssimazione che si può ottenere. E continua ad essere un'
area di ricerca interessante e attiva. Per concludere la lezione, diamo uno sguardo alla tomografia degli stati quantistici
per i qubit e come possiamo farla. Supponiamo quindi che rho sia una matrice densità che rappresenta lo stato di un
singolo qubit, e che X1 fino a Xn siano qubit che sono stati tutti preparati indipendentemente nello stato rho. E per questa
discussione supponiamo che n sia grande. Quello che possiamo fare è dividere i
sistemi in tre gruppi approssimativamente uguali. Per il primo gruppo eseguiremo una misura rispetto alla base
più-meno. Per ogni esito corrispondente a più assegneremo un punteggio di più uno, e per ogni
esito corrispondente a meno assegneremo un punteggio di meno uno. Un modo più conciso per descrivere questa
misura è dire che è una misura di Pauli X, perché gli stati più e meno sono autovettori della matrice di Pauli X e i
corrispondenti autovalori sono più uno e meno uno. E in realtà è anche un modo molto più comune per descriverla.
WEBVTT
In effetti il valore atteso per il punteggio è uguale alla traccia di Sigma x per rho. Non sappiamo necessariamente qual è
questo valore atteso, ma se facciamo la media dei punteggi che otteniamo su molte e molte prove è abbastanza probabile che otteniamo una
buona approssimazione di questo valore atteso, in base alla legge dei grandi numeri. E ci sono alcuni limiti statistici ben noti che possiamo applicare
se vogliamo essere più quantitativi riguardo a quella affermazione. Facciamo qualcosa di simile con Sigma y sul secondo terzo dei
sistemi. L'unica cosa che cambia qui è che usiamo gli stati più i e meno i, che sono autovettori di Sigma
Y. E analogamente per Sigma Z, per il quale i vettori della base standard sono autovettori.
E infine possiamo usare la formula mostrata sullo schermo, che ci dice quali dovrebbero essere i coefficienti
se rho è scritta come combinazione lineare delle matrici di Pauli. E sostituendo le nostre approssimazioni per questi coefficienti
e possibilmente aggiustandoli un po' per assicurarci di ottenere una matrice semidefinita positiva, otteniamo un'approssimazione di
rho. Ovviamente ci sono dettagli che non ho approfondito, come la precisione dell'approssimazione e il grado di
confidenza che possiamo sperare di avere. Ma si spera che ti dia un'idea di base di uno dei modi in cui la tomografia può essere eseguita su un
qubit. È anche possibile fare la tomografia del qubit usando la misura tetraedrica, e in effetti questo risulta essere
abbastanza semplice ed elegante, almeno in termini matematici. Quello che possiamo fare è eseguire solo
questa unica misura su tutte le copie indipendenti del nostro stato quantistico sconosciuto. Usando la
notevole formula mostrata qui, possiamo ottenere un'approssimazione del nostro stato stimando la traccia di PK per
rho per ogni K tramite la frazione di volte in cui appare il corrispondente esito della misura. Di nuovo, questo funziona solo grazie alle
perfette simmetrie che abbiamo tra questi quattro stati. E ci sono in effetti alcuni problemi irrisolti davvero affascinanti che riguardano le generalizzazioni
di questo approccio a sistemi più grandi. Ed è un buon punto in cui fermare la lezione. Grazie per aver guardato e
spero che ti unirai a me per la prossima lezione, che tratta le purificazioni e la fedeltà. Arrivederci per ora.